so these unilateral decisions by the
administration is Congress playing at
any part in these discussions they're
not tom these are unilateral decisions
this was a recommendation by defense
secretary Chuck Hagel to the president a
few days ago the president authorized
that those 130 advisors landed in Erbil
actually yesterday they're a mix of
Special Operations and Marines but Tom
to your point right now the
administration feels on the actions that
they're taking because they've been
invited by the Iraqis there for
complying with international law and
because these are short-term actions
that they don't need to report to
Congress at least immediately you will
see a notice to Congress probably in the
next 24 hours related to the War Powers
Act but they can do this on their own
right now Tom I am confused this morning
about where this goes and the bloomberg
news articles there's a discussion
tentative of migrating to 10,000 troops
how tentative is that is there a plan
that I it's I would say this all sorts
of plans are on the table right now over
the Pentagon they have to be prepared
for anything nobody at the White House
thinks that putting 10,000 troops in in
an advisory capacity or in a boots on
the ground these are combat actions
capacity is even remotely tenable I do
think that Pentagon officials are
briefing the White House right now what
we've heard from administration
officials are both of the State
Department and the Pentagon there's a
very real recognition that the seven
hundred advisors that are in there right
now the work that they're doing on the
humanitarian side to try and help these
ed refugees stuck on the top of Mount
Sinjar simply are not going to have a
long-term impact these are short kind of
band put a band-aid over something types
of issues there has to be something more
that's done 10,000 troops just aren't on
the table at least from the White House
perspective Phil you have reported that
dick Durbin the Senate Majority Leader
obviously a Democrat is supportive of
President Obama up to a point do 130
advisers on the ground fall within the
point of support you're towing that line
Adam I think look the president when it
comes to anything he does on this issue
over the next couple weeks is lucky in
the sense that everybody's at home for
August recess so there's not a lot of
makers that can get to the microphones
there's not a lot of lawmakers that
aren't focused on campaigns right now
that can come back and give him a really
hard time I think the White House and
what you seen from the administration on
these 130 advisors Adam is they're
trying to kind of hit the sweet spot
here these 130 advisors are going
explicitly to work on the humanitarian
issue to work on the refugees this is
something that appeals to Democrats this
is something that dick Durbin
specifically he said he's supportive of
I think every time you send a new
authorization of advisers particularly
even if they're in advisory capacity
Special Forces troops members of
Congress are going to start getting
weary there's not going to be a lot more
of these that can occur at them before
people start raising major major
concerns all right Thank You Phil
Mattingly joining us from Washington